Salut. Il y a quelques jours
j'étais en tournée à Grenoble.
En fait, j'ai fait 6 représentations
à Grenoble
qui étaient complètes !
Merci à vous Grenoble !
Des fois, vous demandez
ce qu'il y a dans le spectacle.
Et bien, ceux qui ont vu le spectacle,
dites le dans les commentaires.
Grosso modo c'est un spectacle d'humour,
durant 1h30 où je vous bluffe en même temps
et vous vous auto-bluffez des fois.
Je ne peux pas en dire plus.
Je... Je suis sur écoute et on pourrait
m'abattre pour en dire plus...
Bref. Vous avez les dates de tournée
dans la description, mais ce n'est pas le propos
C'est surtout, qu'en étant là-bas,
on est allé faire un Escape Game
avec Diablozaure.
Tu sais, mon régisseur.
[Voix rauque] Diablosaure...
Comme j'étais à Grenoble, j'ai aussi
demandé à Youtunes si ça le tentait.
Je n'ai pas pensé à demander à
Chris,  à Poisson Fécond,
on l'a vu le lendemain.
Mais bref, on s'est fait un petit
Escape Game des familles.
Alors forcément, on ne peut pas trop
filmer dans un Escape Game.
En tout cas, on ne peut pas filmer
la résolution des énigmes.
Mais l'Escape Game Arena m'a quand même
permis de sortir la caméra.
Merci à eux.
C'était pas obligé.
Et je vous ai demandé,
sur les réseaux sociaux,
si vous préfériez que je mette
les passages de l'Escape Game
dans le Vlog ?
Qui sort demain d'ailleurs.
Il sort demain matin.
Ou si vous préfériez que j'en fasse
une vidéo complète,
un peu rapide...
[Voix de fausset] Une vidéo
un petit peu différente aujourd'hui.
Bon, je vous ai demandé
sur les résaux sociaux.
Si vous ne m'avez pas répondu :
Ben fallait me suivre sur Facebook,
Twitter ou Instagram...
Et ça, c'est dans la description
comme toujours.
Et vous m'avez répondu que vous
préfériez une vidéo isolée.
Et bé c'est celle-ci !
Et ben voilà !
[Musique générique]
Révélation : vous allez enfin
connaître la vérité !
Salut. Aujourd'hui je suis à
un Escape Game,
l'Escape Game
"Escape Arena"
Hmf... Tu as vu à mon regard que
j'ai regardé parce que je ne me souvenais plus.
On vient avec Diablo et
un petit invité surprise !
du nom de Youtunes.
Alias Jordan, mais il faut savoir
un truc sur Youtunes...
Je lui ai dit :
Rendez-vous à 11h,
au 31 rue Gustave Eiffel.
Comme il était 11h et qu'il
n'était pas là,
je l'ai appelé. Il me fait :
"Mais non, tu m'as dit rendez-vous à 11h31"
Mais qui, dans ta vie, te donne
rendez-vous à 11h31 ?
Tu vois mec ?
Il me fait :
"Ben si ! Tu m'as donné rendez-vous
à 11h31, rue Gustave Eiffel."
Je me dis que s'il n'a pas choppé
cette bonne info dans le SMS,
je pense qu'on va rester enfermés
ad vitam æternam dans l'Escape Game.
[Fab] Du coup, je pense que Youtunes peut
avoir deux, trois heures de retard là...
[Diablo] Février 2018...
[Éclat de rire de Fabien]
[Diablo] Février 2019...
[Diablo ronfle puis avec une voix étrange]
2021...
[Diablo] Aaaaaaah !!!
[Fab] C'était ça !
Il est de retour ! L'enfant prodige de la musique
de Youtube est de retour. C'est Youtunes.
[Voix de ténor] Youtuuunes !
[You] Salut à tous.
[Loïc] Souvent dans un Escape Game,
vous allez pouvoir tout retourner,
ça fait partie du jeu en général.
Mais là, dans cette pièce là,
tout ce qui est sur les murs,
vous avez interdiction d'y toucher.
Pour éviter que ça ruine des énigmes
pour vous, derrière.
[Loïc] L'iphone 8...
[Fabien]Wouhaou !
[Loïc] Haute technologie,
regardez bien.
Maintenant, vous êtes beaucoup plus
curieux que ça
et vous vous dites que s'ils vous ont interdit
d'entrer là-dedans, c'est que, forcément, il y a une raison
et vous voulez fouiller cette pièce mystérieuse
pour voir si elle ne cache pas des choses intéressantes
Qu'une chose soit claire :
si, quand ils reviennent,
vous êtes encore à l'intérieur...
Je ne sais pas ce que vous faites,
je ne sais pas où vous êtes,
et c'est votre problème.
[Diablo - Voix rauque ] Allez, venez !
[You] J'y vais ?
[Fab] Ah, ben bien-sûr.
[Fab] Moi je vais dans le bureau de papy,
de toute manière, avec le cousin Loïc.
[Loïc] Ouais, ouais. On ira.
A tout de suite.
[Fabien fredonne]
[You] Okay !
[Loïc] Allez les cousins, faites vite.
A tout à l'heure.
[La porte claque]
[Fab] 'tin c'est un sauna les mecs !
[You] Ah, sans déconner...
[Fab] Il est sympa ce petit sauna, hein ?
[Diablo] Tu crois que c'est papy
et mamy là ?
[Fab] Alors. On est censés trouver une
feuille, les gars.
[Fab] Attends ! Je crois qu'il fait
partie du truc.
[On entend une musique]
[Fab] Regarde. Juste ici... une clef.
[Diablo siffle d'admiration]
[Fab] Je lui ai pris dans la poche, à Loïc
[You] Lourd...
[Fab] juste avant de partir.
[Diablo - avec un accent] Lampe à UV !
[Fab] Lampe qui nous permettra de voir
des inscriptions quelque part.
[You] Et peut-être que...
[Diablo] Sur la feuille !
[Fab] Attends, moi c'est plus par là
que je ....  [Rires]
[Diablo] Arrrh !
[Fab] Fais voir tes mains !
[Gary] On éteint ?
[Fab] Il a une chaîne Youporn, Diablo...
[Diablo] On éteint, on éteint, on éteint...
[You] Ben, je pense, mais alors...
[You] Peut-être les cadres.
[Diablo] On éteint, on regarde.
[cacophonie]
[Fab - voix du désespoir]
Si vous retrouvez cette caméra...
On a la clef !
[Chantant] Je suis Passe-Partout...
[Fab] Tiens, prends. Je veux juste...
[Diablo] Aaaah !
[Fab] Prends le, j'ouvre l'armoire.
Mais prends de très près,
qu'on ne voit pas trop le large
après je resserrerai.
[on entend la clef déverrouiller la porte]
[Musique d'ambiance ajoutée au montage]
[Diablo] Aaannn...
[You] J'adore la musique que ça fait
[Fab] Non, mais... ça ne nous appartient pas.
[Fab] Moi je dis qu'on doit respecter
Papy et Mamy.
[You] Moi je pense qu'on devrait partir.
[Diablo immite le grincement
d'une vielle porte qui s'ouvre]
[You] Aaahh...
[Diablo émet un grognement d'outre tombe]
[Fab] Non, laisse... laisse la clef ici.
[La voix de Loïc sort du Talki-Walki]
Qu'est-ce qui se passe les cousins ?
[Diablo] On arrive dans une chambre noire.
[Loïc] Ah, j'espère que vous n'avez
pas peur du noirs.
[Loïc] Bon, les cousins, je ne vous cache pas
qu'il va falloir vous dépêcher là
Papy et Mamy seront de retour
dans 50 minutes !
[Fab] 50 minutes !?
[Diablo] Faut rien casser. Mets un grand coup de savate dans le...
[Une voix enregistrée se fait entendre]
[Fab] Voilà. C'est ici que le jeu commence.
On a déjà mis une demi-heure...
[Rires]
[You] Ah ouaiiiis !
[You] C'est sympa, ça.
[Fab] Ça sent le "narcotraficantes"
*avec l'accent espagnol*
[Diablo] Ah ! Il y a une feuille.
[Fab - accent] Pablo Escobar est de retour.
[Fab] Alors là, on est dans une pièce
vraiment chelou
[You] C'est maintenant que je brille !
[Fab] C'est maintenant qu'il brille !
[You] Maintenant on brille tous !
[Fab] Okay ?!
[Fab] On a foi en vous.
Je coupe un petit peu dans les résolutions
des énigmes, les amis, c'est bien normal.
Parce que si, un jour, vous venez faire
cet Escape Game, ça n'aurait aucun intérêt sinon.
[Fab] Bon. Là, pour l'instant, on a ouvert un coffre,
on a eu des documents hyper top-secret,
et, euh... il faut qu'on appelle le...
le je ne sais pas quoi
mais on va l'appeler.
[You] Le R S VI X, c'est le...
Oui. Bonsoir. C'est pour une 4 fromages,
s'il vous plaît.
Tu veux quoi ?
[You] Pepsi et...
juste une bière avec.
[Fab] Pepsi et euh...
[You] Dans le pepsi !
[Fab] Pepsi et dans le Pepsi. On va dire 3 fois Pepsi parce que c'est un placement de produit.
Voilà. Merci.
Ok
En vrai... on avance plus là.
[You] Non !
[Fab] En appelant le R, M, S, I, X
La lettre E
[Bip - Bip]
[Diablo] Oh put***
[You] Ça s'ouvre !
[Fab] C'est bon !
[You] Mais vous ne verrez pas ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur.
[Loïc - Talki] Je ne sais pas ce que vous
êtes en train de faire, là,
mais Papy et Mamy seront de retour
dans 35 minutes.
[Fab] Ouais, ben t'avais qu'à venir avec nous !
Sans déconner...
[Fab] Le mec il a les foies et il vient pas dans le...
[Diablo] Hé ! Les gars !
[Fab] Oh ! La clef !
[Talki - On comprend mal]
.... dans le bureau
[Fab] Qu'est-ce qu'il dit ?
[You & Diablo] Il va s'enfermer dans le bureau.
[Fab] D'accord. Ben... fait comme ça !
Et euh....
T'aurais dû venir avec nous.
[You] Ouais.
[Diablo] Hé, regarde ! On peut sortir par là !
[Rires]
[Fab] YT, c'est un C...
[You] A Z
[Fab] A Z, ça doit être euh... V
[You] T V
[You] F, D, E
[Fab] Comme un F et un D ?
[You] F, D et E ouais
[Fab] F, D ...
[Un coup de feu retentit]
[Quelqu'un pousse un cri]
[Deuxième coup de feu]
[Diablo] Put*** le général a sauté !
[Rires]
[Fab]... planqué sous la table
[You] Ah, merde, attends,
il nous faut une lampe !
[On tambourine sur la porte]
[Diablo] C'est occupé !
[On tambourine]
[You] Euh... ouais !
[You] Partez ! Vous n'êtes pas cool !
[Diablo immite un miaulement de chat]
[Fab] C'est bon !
No l'imitation du chat...
[Un bruit sourd]
[Une voix derrière la porte semble parler en Russe]
[Fabien répond en "Russe"]
[Diablo] On ne peut pas ouvrir,
on a pas trouvé la clef !
[Fab] Je vais lui demander
ce qu'il veut boire.
"что вы хотите пить"
[Diablo - criant à travers la porte]
On a perdu la clef, René !
[Fab] Hé ! Continue de traduire, ...
[You] Merci. Euh... ça c'est chiant.
[Fab] Oooh, Jacouille !
[You] It's euh... chiant !
[You] Vite, vite, vite, vite ! Ils arrivent !
Papy et Mamy !  Aaaahhh !
[Fab] Ça serait trop beau. Ça ne
rentre pas là-dedans ça
[You] Et l'autre ?
[Fab] Non, non. Je pense qu'il nous manque
encore une dernière chose...
[Voix émise par le Talki-Walki]
[Fab] Ce n'est pas possible ça...
[Talki] Ils commencent à s'énerver..
[Fab] Oh put*** ! Mais pourquoi on en a
2 de plus, on ne sait pas...
oh put*** on est bons.
Attends.
Hé ! Tu sais quoi ?
On range un peu !
[Rires]
[You] Ouais... euh...
[Fab] Cassons-nous, cassons-nous...
On oublie rien ?
[Diablo] On oublie rien.
[Ils toussent]
[Fab] Ça doit être par là !
Dans l'armoire les mecs !
[You] On va vers...
[Fab] Incroyable ! Vas-y, vas-y, vas-y !
Ouvre la porte !
[Diablo] Ouais !
[Fab] Liberté !
[Loïc] Félicitations !
[You] Merci cousin !
[Fab] Papy ! Mamy ! Cousin !
[Fab] Un des trois, c'est sûr !
[Loïc] C'est sûr.
[Fab] Oui, allô ? Concernant cette 4 fromages
et ce Pepsi...
[Bruit sourd]
[Fab] Placement de produit
[You] A la bière !
[Fab] A la bière ! Merci.
[Fab] Alors, on a mis combien de
temps en vrai ?
[Loïc] 57 minutes et 14 secondes.
[You] Ah ouais !
[Diablo] Et c'est bien d'être plusieurs, ouais.
[Diablo] Parce que tout seul...
[Fab] Parce qu'on n'a pas tous la même logique
[Diablo] Moi, en 2024, je suis encore là.
C'est sûr !
[You] Mais, on est en 2024 Diablo.
[Diablo] Après cette folle partie,
une autre folle partie s'annonce !
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
J'espère que ça vous aura plu.
C'est un chouette Escape Game
parce que le... euh...
Il est très immersif en fait.
Si vous avez l'occasion d'aller
à Grenoble, allez-y
ce n'est pas une chaîne d'Escape Game
c'est un privé.
Euh... On est allé là-bas un petit
peu par hasard
mais c'était un heureux hasard.
L'équipe est cool et les énigmes
sont vraiment chouettes.
On a mis 57 minutes à sortir du Game.
Ce n'était donc pas si simple !
N'oubliez pas : Si !
Et seulement si !
la vidéo vous a plu, de mettre un like,
c'est très important,
vous pouvez également vous
abonner à la chaîne
si ce n'est pas encore fait.
Et rendez-vous demain,
pour le Vlog mensueeellll.
Ciao.
[Musique Générique de Fin]